luís flores un joven de 22 años quedó a
cargo de ocho hermanos de entre 2 y 18
años tras la muerte de su madre ocurrida
hace un año por falta de atención médica
cuando sufría por varios males y los
hospitales estaban colapsados por la
pandemia la verdad y ha sido muy difícil
para mí muy difícilmente ni qué bueno
alejar de muchas cosas que se olvidan el
incluso de mí misma no contaminamos para
apoyar también a mis hermanos que estén
bien que estén tranquilos tal vez si se
hubiese salvado puede que no yo sólo
había sabe pero se cree que nos atienden
el momento no había ningún hospital la
defensoría del pueblo ha pedido al
parlamento aprobar varios beneficios
para los huérfanos de la pandemia como
subsidios económicos y prohibir que sus
tutores sean despedidos hemos visto que
en la realidad son los hermanos mayores
los que se están haciendo cargo y para
ellos era importante poder ayudarles con
una fuente de empleo en algunos en
algunas situaciones de mayor precariedad
de la posibilidad de que se puedan
implementar programas de vivienda
la defensoría calcula que las ayudas
podrían beneficiar en principio a 1600
huérfanos pero en el parlamento ven
factibles sólo medidas que no impliquen
erogaciones altas de dinero por la
crisis económica otro problema es
identificar a los posibles beneficiarios
ya que no todas las muertes cuentan con
las certificaciones de kobe
y exámenes
estigmatice
con esta
y mientras el parlamento intenta
resolver sus propias dudas louis
continúa trabajando para atender a sus
ocho hermanos porque las ayudas todavía
son inciertas